I'm 17 so I'm still doing it for fun you
know I don't think of it as a career
well I do I take it seriously but the
way I keep myself sane is by thinking of
it as
have a steamer like a local steamer the
Hydra vocal cords I need to do that an
hour before I go on stage
just chill you know a kite I try not to
get I try not to like walk around the
stage too much because then I'll get
nervous
so just chill back and wait for the time
to come in you know I get very antsy so
I just relax me
make my mind up think watching two
videos I drink manuka honey with Roco
it's kind of like my secret remedy for
singing if I need to drink that if I
don't drink that I'll freaked out a
little bit I did a show in Danforth in
Toronto where I'm from and there's about
300 people showed up so it's like 300
people I did a 40 minute set of covers
and one song and then I had another 300
people came in they sold like two shows
in the same night so I to 40-minute set
working on new music I'm finishing up
the tour with Taylor Swift and then
headline shows you know
there's always on the move always
stirring always making music